my guest tonight has appeared in
numerous films including footloose
mystic river and jfk
and now you can see him in the showtime
very city on a hill thrilled he's
joining us please welcome our friend
kevin
bacon kevin how are you i'm doing okay
how are you handling
the uh the quarantine situation are you
finding that you
are doing things now that you've never
done before
uh yeah i definitely am finding that i'm
doing things i've never done before
you know i've done a certain amount of
cleaning in my life but the truth is is
that
now we're in this situation where
clearly we don't have anybody to you
know to help us with the cleaning
we clean all day long we do it
dawn till dusk the laundry i just i
literally just cleaned the toilets
before i
put put on my um jacket um and uh
it's kevin kevin that's something that's
something we didn't need to know
[Laughter]
i washed my hands within an inch of
their life believe me i love that
i love that on your to-do list it said
one clean
toilet two talk to conan
you've got your you gotta plan your days
man uh you're in this situation i think
i'm in a situation too
where if you go out in the world uh
people usually want a selfie uh
you're probably finding that that has
kind of gone away
it's it's over it's over yeah you know i
listen
we were um taking a walk the other day
this was actually about probably about
two weeks ago
and uh kira said to me hey
have you noticed that nobody stops you
for selfies anymore i said yeah that's
social distancing
yeah no it's it's but also i feel like
even before all this happened in our
other lives
um i have the kind of face that says he
looks sad
i want to go take a picture with him to
cheer him up
whereas you being in the movie business
you can sometimes probably have more of
that
you know that thing jack nicholson has
where he can he can
his very expression can mean don't come
near me do you know what i mean
which i've never mastered that i don't
have that but
do you have that are you able to do that
sometimes i do and i don't even really
know and i'm not even it's not really
even something that i'm consciously
aware of
my kids and my wife will tell me that i
have this kind of
like uh you know don't
it's it's it's like built in social
distancing in my face do you think that
maybe that comes from your philly side i
know that you're originally from
philadelphia philly is tough and
sometimes you probably are able to
access on a genetic level
your philly side of kevin bacon i think
that's true
philly definitely has a kind of like
don't mess with me
sort of um vibe and and certainly you
know growing up
uh there were times when um
really not out of any kind of uh courage
but really out of terror
i would have to put that face on if i
was walking around in in the hopes that
i was gonna you know
stave off and attack
hey if it works for you if you can if
you have a face that can defend you
uh good for you i don't have that do you
ever slip into a philly accent when
you're talking to people
oh yeah my friends will tell me what
what just happened how come you're
talking like that all of a sudden you're
going like
what what's going on with you um yeah i
do
it's a weird accent because nobody
really does it you know
like people don't do you you don't grow
up hearing it in movies
you know you hear boston you hear new
york you know everyone grew up with you
know
whatever the godfather and you know all
the scorsese stuff
but philly is like rarely rarely done
and um i always like to have a
conversation between two guys where he's
going
uh hey where are you going for lunch um
i'm going on a while
what are you going to get i don't know
hogan to coke really what kind of what
kind of hokey i'm a cheesesteak hog
maybe
um peppers and onions you're drinking
coke no i mean diet
what diet coke you're on a diet no i'm
not a diet i'm just drinking diet coke
there's a movie right there that is the
opening scene whenever i hear a boston
accent in a movie
because i grew up in boston uh i'm
shocked at how many times it
sounds like a cartoon caricature of a
boston accent
like uh the perfect storm there's a part
where
the ship's heading into the storm
and i think some woman says he's headed
into the jaws of the monster
and yeah i'm just like oh my god
to me that's terrifying in the storm
listen i've
i've done probably six uh
boston characters and i'm doing a boston
character now and i can tell you that
i i have given myself over to the
reality that
no matter how good your boston accent is
people from boston are never going to
like it
no it's just it's just that's just the
thing
and like there was a time when i was
kind of like well maybe
you know maybe i'll be able to make the
people of the greater boston area happy
this time and
then i finally just gave up and said
well i'll just you know i just got to do
it
the people of boston don't want to be
happy
[Laughter]
they're not looking for that